reporting live from Mexico City I am
falling for Ben that's me
Olivia continued to cause drama on The
Bachelor Monday night offending pretty
much the entire group after she made
this comment while amanda was discussing
her kids feel like it's been episode of
Teen Mom that I watch wait what woman I
feel like it's an episode of Teen Mom
first of all I was 22 when I had my
first now it's 24 when I had my second
just a little confused like I don't
really understand you common sense not
to like tell somebody that you're a
minor legatine you know I'm learning a
lot about myself then
all right I want you guys to know that
um I'm really like I'm gonna try harder
from here on out but those tears yeah
the girls weren't buying it these tears
are not authentic at all they're fake
I think she's rude I think she's selfish
a few contestants felt so strongly they
confronted Ben about the 23 year old
news anchor I'm around Olivia it's great
but when I hear these women talk to me
it just seems like a different person
it's really made me question my feelings
for her Olivia uh can I talk with you
yeah sure
one thing Ben was sure of letting
Jubilee go it would be unfair of me to
tell you that I thought that something
it exists I think it's best that tonight
maybe we sing about it I would have
loved him unconditionally
Nathan